he's the Eagles tight end zach urged did
you hear about me talking about you I
did not hear about it okay but one of
your producers told me both before I got
in that you came in yesterday fired up
so I appreciate the love I'm definitely
not gonna argue your stance I'm all
aboard who's the best tight end in
football I think there are four guys
right now that are kind of the top in my
opinion obviously Travis drawn Jordan
and I like to put myself up there with
those guys I'm not going to back down
from that but I think there are four
really good guys right now and then FL
what do they do differently than you or
better than you I mean there's always
gonna be so differences between the guys
at the top I mean if you look at the
wide receiver position with Antonio
Brown or del Julio those are kind of
three guys they're all different and I
think with the tight end it's kind of
the same thing I mean Gronk is a beast
obviously I think Travis is probably the
best after the catch
Morgan's a phenomenal route runner and I
think I'm kind of up there with all of
them I'm not gonna say that my game is
lacking by any means but I think all of
us do different things and it's kind of
whatever you like
it's gonna be the one you pick five
catches eighty nine yards a touchdown
against Washington Monday night feel
different to you I know it's a day later
but how different does it feel when
you're playing on Monday night as
opposed to Sunday afternoon I mean
anytime you get a prime-time game it's
fun but I think Monday is extremely
special because it's the only game of
the week and you could say Thursday is
the only game of the week too but
Thursday is so tough on the body and
mentally trying to prepare on such a
short week but Monday you have a full
week and an extra day to prepare so
everyone's at a hundred percent or as
close to a hundred percent as you're
going to be and it's pretty much the
game of the week in terms of the NFL
picks this game before the season even
starts say this is a game with a and
whenever we play Monday night at home is
so much fun because our fans are so
riled up they're so either DUP like
so it's a great atmosphere what's
different about carson wentz this year's
opposed to last year was so tough i
think not only for him but all of us he
was named the starter eight days before
the Browns game last year so I think the
whole year we were kind of playing
catch-up and whereas this year I mean he
came with the season as a face of the
franchise the face of Philadelphia
really he's so comfortable in his hole
here that guy who loved playing with
them
so I think our whole team has kind of
taken his leadership and just ran with
it I mean we have so much confidence
teaching every time we step on the field
because he has so much confidence and uh
so it's so much fun playing with them
and we love to have another quarterback
she kind of a nerd I mean come from
Stanford so are you a nerd doesn't do
much else outside of it besides I think
hunting is a big hobby he loves to do
that but I think you just fully invested
in the game of football I know you're
friends with Andrew Luck on a scale of
one to ten nerds nerd scale where is
Andrew Luck on the nerd scale is he
first pallet all nerd yeah I mean he's
just so smart I mean the guy says three
brothers a quarterback all right tell me
if this sounds like Andrew Luck your
former quarterback at Stanford haha CLEC
glad to hear from Zach Ertz good body
and Zinzi not a lot of tight ends and an
Aussie Z we actually we did it to luck
and he and he actually admitted that it
was pretty good give me your favorite
Jim Harbaugh story is there a recruiting
story when I committed committed in
person and the guy literally jumped into
my arms on the practice field of spring
it was spring ball at Stanford I said
coach I'm gonna come to Stanford I'm
coming to Stanford next thing I know he
is full bear-hug in my lab pretty much
thank you
he's a Kurtz the Eagles tight in joining
his Dan Patrick showed the best athlete
the family is who sees the best in the
world in my opinion what she does it's
hard to argue that
so she's the starting defender on the
u.s. women's national soccer team was
there that video when didn't she get get
hit in the face or in the forehead and
and that she had all that blood and I
don't know if she still stayed in the
game can you fill me in on the details
on that I thought it was her for some
reason that that was brought to my
attention but you would know better than
I would so I'll take your word for it
but Julie is a starting defender on the
u.s. women's national team the best team
in the NFC right now is every Sunday and
I think it stems from our head coach
coach Peterson he did instill that
confidence and obviously with a
quarterback like Carson every time we
step on the field we expect to win right
now I think we're playing really good
football but we're not satisfied by any
means we a lot of tough games coming up
and I'm so excited about the rest of the
season
it's gonna be a fun one I think the old
cities kind of run out has a great
energy and vibe right now it's work
started with where we're at I'll tell
you what I'm gonna do for you and Julie
and and we've never met but I'm gonna
get you into the Pro Bowl this year
there we go yeah little vacation you
guys go to Disney World and get to go to
the Pro Bowl and then the world gets to
see Zach herds best tight end in
football we'll do it together but you
got to help me a little bit okay oh yeah
yeah until Wednesday
tell winch to throw you the ball a
little bit more do you ever go back to
the huddle and say dude I was open okay
throw me the ball I just gotta go with
the flow if I get the ball great if I
don't as long as we win I'm happy all
right well hey congrats on the season so
far
and good luck we'll get you into the Pro
Bowl at the end of the year there you go
just making dreams come true for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]